now let's do the real test we took two
stunt people that were the exact body
mass of Kate and Leo so we did exactly
what what they did in the movie
except that we doubled the time for
every stage of it because our water
wasn't as cold
and a guy pushes her under one one
thousand two one thousand back up
one one thousand two one thousand and
Jackson's over yeah
all right swim Rose and the faster your
heart's beating the faster that cooling
blood from your arms and legs is coming
into your core taking your temperature
down so I was really curious to see what
that did to Jack's situation and it's
pretty interesting
what we saw was that he got up on there
and he immediately went into the really
strong shaking shivering right the
answer was there was no way they could
both survive